okay thank you pablo thank you again for
the invitation so i think this talk is
gonna feel like a little bit like a
tractability interlude okay so things
are a lot easier here that they should
be uh to the point of being almost uh
supernatural and
and so i'm going to talk about a highly
classical problem
and related to rank aggregation so some
of the authors the organizers have
worked on this it's very easy to
describe your you have n items and there
could be anything you like um
products people and so on uh and you
have a set of compile you have a little
bit of information on comparison or
preferences between these items okay so
you know that for a subset of the pairs
ij
you know that item i is better than item
j
okay
and based on that you want to find a
global ranking of the items
okay so it's hunk aggregation if you
have very partial it's a particular case
of rank aggregation you have pairwise
information on ranking and you want to
aggregate this pairwise information to
create a global ordering okay
that's it very ancient problem uh
it shows up in many many fields of
course one of the most natural settings
where this shows up is tournaments
sports tournaments okay typically one
team faces another so you have a pair
pairwise preference information or
pairwise
comparison that shows up your tournament
is many many of those pairs and you want
to produce a ranking out of the results
but in many other cases the reason why
pairwise information shows up is that it
when the question asked is a bit more
abstract
it's sometimes much easier to
reply in terms of relative preferences
rather than produce an absolute score
so there are these websites
similar to hot or not who try to rank
people's hotness
and if i give you one picture
okay giving an absolute ranking on
hotness is difficult but now if i give
you a pair of pictures ranking hotness
is somehow a lot easier okay
the other order is something subjective
so i'm not gonna say anything
um and and so um but but this is also
used heavily in marketing for example
one of the two the two authors of a
paper on on pairwise ranking at jamison
and novak use it to rank beers
and the way it works is that you taste
two beers
and you decide if you prefer one versus
the other you do that a couple of times
of course it has to stop you have a
limited
be a budget in this case and then the
the method will produce a ranking okay
and they have an app doing that and so
on
okay so it's
in some some cases it's that's the way
the data is produced in other cases it's
a much more intuitive way of producing
ranking information
okay so it's an extremely old problem uh
and
over the years of course a number of
algorithms have been developed
and so i'm just going to quickly start
by surveying the main categories of
results on on this um
honking
aggregation so there's the cheapest
thing you can think of and if i give you
two minutes to come up with an algorithm
on this uh it is scoring okay so you
take the preference information for each
item or each person or each beer and so
on and you produce a score based on the
number of wins essentially
and then you could just trunk items
according according to the scores right
that's usually extremely cheap
unfortunately you get what you bargained
for uh it's usually not that robust okay
uh there are more sophisticated versions
of this this scoring system one
classical well-known system is the elo
rating system in chess i'll give a bit
more details about this there's a true
skill there's a ranking system produced
by microsoft for online gaming and so on
so it you can refine this a lot okay and
of course
the quality of the solution improves
them
significantly as well so that's the
first type of solutions you just produce
a score compare the score okay
second time of solution is a bit more
subtle uh they're they're based on the
spectral argument and this is will be
the main theme today okay and let's say
a few more things about that but clearly
you work with a matrix you capture a lot
more information about your preference
information and in this case you you pay
a little bit a numerical price that's
slightly higher but you get a lot more
robustness
okay
yes
this has been used in this context
in general for sporting ranking since
the 1930s and
the analytic hierarchy process
by tom saty was started by tom saty is a
huge area that's based on using the
agent
yes yes yes yes yes so i i'm just
surveying uh things that have been done
before this border dates back from the
18th century
to give references from 2000 on for the
spectral method you should have given
the references for uh oh okay so yes one
disclaimer this this slide should
contain uh you know uh several orders of
magnitude more references than it's a
massive field so of course i'm omitting
a lot of stuff but i'm gonna make
references to this work in particular
and what follows hence the reason why
i'm citing those of course i'm
forgetting a lot of people um and so so
special methods that say a few more
things about uh those later the key idea
here is that well the the it's also you
can see uh the matrix as a sort of way
of capturing the preferences aggregating
the preference information there's work
by the
organizers who i haven't cited either
on the wrong aggregation based on atomic
norm arguments
there is classic work in statistics on
maximum likelihood estimation meth
on maximum likelihood-based estimation
where you put a probabilistic model
behind your observations on preferences
and then you try to infer your ranking
information by maximizing likelihood
okay classic references include bradley
terrellus
in the 50s but of course a lot more many
more people in this
in this vein as well
and finally uh in sort of increasing
order of complexity um there are
algorithms that use learning methods
like super vector machines to learn a
ranking
based on a feature set generated from
the preference information okay so just
this is by increasing order of
complexity scores are almost direct in
some sense spectral methods take an
eigenvalue computation something of
order and square
mle requires maximizing likelihood you
solve an optimization problem it can be
a bit more expensive even though there
are fixed point based algorithms to
solve these things efficiently and this
requires uh solving something like a
supervisor machine and so it's again a
little bit more expensive okay
there is a
for everything that's missing in this
slide uh we have a solution um one of
the co-authors here is producing a
survey book on the topic that should be
out soon so and that hopefully covers in
a lot more depth uh the literature on
the topic okay
so uh that's that's uh about algorithms
of course the the problem itself has a
different nature if you in in
many of these
references so in many cases for example
a partial subset of preferences is
observed not a full one
well
you can also be in a case where the
preferences are fully observed but
arbitrarily corrupted
there's a lot of work on actively
measuring preferences so choosing
preferences so that you have uh you you
maximize your
the quality of the reconstruct request
for the ranking using a limited budget
of measurements and uh in the
statistical settings so all these
maximum likelihood estimation methods
typically i should assume that you have
you can make repeated observations and
of course depending on the application
you work with repeated observations are
possible or not okay
and
obviously performance metrics vary to
in a significant way
a combinatorial way of measuring the
quality of a solution is to measure the
number of disagreements okay
and how does that work well you have a
reconstructed order
you simply count the number of arcs that
point in the direction opposite to the
order you've established okay so these
are inconsistent arcs you count them and
that's going to be your performance
metric
and
here yes this is odin
yes
what do you mean original accounting
yes yes yes
no you don't say by how much
you have to say by how much it depends
some spectral methods the one i'm going
to discuss here you don't say by how
much you just point so but i'll come to
that just wait two slides and we'll be
there
um so
that's it so that's one way you you can
try to minimize the
feedback arc set this is the the set of
arcs that point backwards compared to
your uh
reconstructed order and there's actually
a pts for doing that okay on tournaments
so it turns out that on tournaments at
least this problem is easier than it
should be
because you can find a pts of course its
complexity is even higher than the
complexity i've discussed before
and
well in some cases you're trying to
maximize likelihood so that's your
objective it's a completely different
measure of performance convex loss in
ranking as vms so
it's a single problem but there are many
many approaches and it's it's sometimes
hard to directly compare the performance
of one method compared to another okay
so uh even comparing algorithms on
comparisons is hard
sorry
so just again a very quick survey of
what's uh what's possible just because
it's interesting to see
the wealth of methods that have been
applied to this very single specific
aggregation problem the board account
dates back to at least the 18th century
and in this case it's very
straightforward the players are ranked
according to the number of wins divided
by the total number of comparisons okay
so if i give you two minutes to come up
with a direct way of comparing of
reconstructing an order based on
pairwise preferences this is probably
something you you would come up with but
there's a very long list of variants i'm
citing a few here
the elo system is interesting and i'm
just going to detail it a little bit
more here
and it looks a lot like the
statistical methods that
will follow in the elo system players
have a skill level new i it's the yellow
score
okay
and you assume that the probability of
player i beating j is given by a certain
function h which is typically a gaussian
cdf
of the difference between the player
skills okay
and so there is this total skill budget
that's shared by all the players
and every time players play each other
they exchange skills okay according to a
formula
uh so
when mu i wins
the this viable w i j is equal to one
and the score mu i of the ice player is
updated according to this rule so it's
the previous score plus a sort of
dividend coming from the wind
the win
minus a penalty on how
easy was this supposed to be okay if
it's an easy win you don't update the
score by much if it's a huge win you do
age is kind of the probability that
the probability that this player with a
skill i would win against the player
with skill j yeah exactly yeah yeah and
so that's usually one you didn't learn
anything from this
experiment so you don't gain anything
precisely and it avoids the system being
gained because then you you you
otherwise you could choose very weak
players beat them and and increase your
score massively and of course that's not
the point okay
so
that's the idea behind elo
dates back from the 70s
and the idea here is that if you look at
the way the equation is updated because
h is a cdf the total skill set of the
group of chess players scored here
doesn't change
so you just exchange skills and that's
it okay
it's like bitcoin after the inflation
ends um and there's a
variation on this system where the the
skill sets of the players are
represented by gaussian distributions
and where you use uh statistical
inference methods to uh
to basically do the same thing you're
doing here okay and again the the main
point of these things here is that the
the numerical cost is is uh
very highly minimal okay so you don't
compute anything
uh from a numerical point of view
so that's one
obvious approach um
slightly different spectral methods
um so the ones i'm gonna mention today
and i'm sure there are others but i'm
gonna
focus on this one in this introduction
are similar to the the classical uh
honking methods from for the web
okay
so on the web you have this this
metaphor of a random surfer
choosing
pages at random landing on a page
looking at links choosing
other pages following a uniform
distribution on the new page and then
you compute the global page ranking
based on the stationary distribution so
the probability in the end asymptotic
probability of this random surfer being
on a certain page okay here for ranking
it's the same thing
to every preference
relationship corresponds the link
okay
and the likelihood so you still have
this random
suffer on the graph of preferences
and the likelihood i've got going from i
to j depends on how often i lost to j
okay so you're gonna visit people
with more wins more frequently
okay
how do you
deal with this issue um
um i don't know actually i don't
remember i'm not gonna talk about this
particular thing today so
good question i don't know we should we
should find out
uh
it's not old enough you're not just
going from i to j it depends if you
repeat measurements or not so in some
statistical models you're allowed to
repeat measurements and then of course
the number of wins can can be more than
binary if you have a
tournament setting then then it's it's
it's uh
okay so it it depends on the setting so
again
this is just a
very strict subset of what's out there i
just wanted to cover in five or ten
minutes as much as i could in terms of
what's existing
obviously i'm missing something okay
um
okay so the good news about this is that
well uh from an intuitive point of view
you're capturing a lot more information
about the preferences and the structure
of preferences in this matrix than you
are doing in the scoring methods okay
because this this
this markov chain captures all of the
preference information you're given and
stores it in a much more robust way okay
and from a numerical point of view
you're only paying a marginally higher
compensation price because well all you
have to do is compute um an eigenvalue
a leading eigenvalue of this
of this matrix of dimension n and the
cost of doing that is proportional to n
square again okay
so is it really that different from the
in the dance case
because you could think of it as kind of
some kind of power method or something
like the previous thing like the update
of the scoring function ah yes you know
from elo
starts to have this dynamical aspect um
hard to say but but at least here the
dependence between the preference
information and the final score is a lot
more
nonlinear
and you expect that to make it a little
bit more robust so this is a completely
informal argument
but what i'm going to try to do at the
end of this talk is make a more formal
argument on robustness based on the
structure on the of the matrix so you
hope that by storing your your
information in this matrix format you
gain in robustness and you pay a
slightly higher medical cost okay
um
any questions otherwise okay so
finally
uh another the last class of methods i'm
going to cover today maximum likelihood
estimation
so here you have a model on on where
this this pairwise information comes
from
it's a statistical model
comparisons are generated according to
this generalized linear model you have
repeated observations they're
independent and item i is preferred over
item j with probability p i j given by h
of nu i
minus nu j okay so it looks very similar
it's similar in spirit to the elo system
it predates it so well the statement
should be made in the opposite direction
uh again here new is a vector of skills
uh h is a cdf typically logistic in the
broadcast i use model but you can also
do it with gaussian or laplace
distributions okay
and so what you do now is just estimate
new by maximizing likelihood okay
and you can do that so you don't have to
really
do it using graduate methods if you
don't want to there's a fixed point
algorithm that that typically works
really fast
okay so that's the last major class of
methods uh i'm gonna
cover and so i'm gonna just zoom on on
some of these methods and focus on the
low complexity end of of these
results okay
and so the current tradeoffs in that
area well
scoring methods are exact in the
noiseless case
it's easy enough to figure out they are
usually designed for that purpose but
they're not very robust okay
so here you assume that there is an
ordering which is consistent with all
the
you don't have to in the
um
that's what you mean by noiseless
oh yes yes that's what i mean by no
sense so i haven't made any assumptions
yet but that's that's what i call
noiseless yes yes yes charlie
you can have a scoring method where
everybody prefers a number one to number
three
but when you take a scoring method it
will give you
numbers in number three higher than
number one i can give you an example by
texting no sure
well the the board account with
noiseless information on the full
preference matrix will give you recover
the exact
ranking
so suppose your rank vibes one two three
four five six seven eight
nine ten
you
get preference information based on that
linear ordering you compute the board
accounts uh
uh
related to that ordering and you
reconstruct the ordering based on the
scores you get uh
you recover the exact ordering that's
that's all i mean by exact
reconstruction
you
take preference information consistent
with a total ordering
you apply the border score to it
yes you get it for you yes
there are examples where you can give
scores and of course it's no no
this is a general statement
to that applies to
the most classical scores board account
in particular
that says that well this board account
in the noiseless case would reconstruct
the total ordering
you assume that you just get all n
squared comparisons exactly they are all
exact
the number of wins tells you exactly
your place yeah yeah yeah that's all i'm
saying that that's just that's all i'm
saying
no no no
and a few slides before i was saying
that in some of the papers i'm citing
the information is partial in some of
the papers i'm citing there is active
choice of preference information so you
can choose the preferences you that it's
and
these through signs are not results i'm
just trying to survey as fast as
possible a very very broad
oh okay okay my apologies then
um anyway so
spectral methods are sorry scoring
methods are exact in the noise this case
at least for most of them by design but
they are not very robust spectral
methods are more robust for reasons i'm
going to discuss later but at least the
ones that are cited here
that that are based on this markov chain
argument don't come with exact recovery
guarantee meaning that if you have full
information noiseless
you you don't have any guarantee to
reconstruct the exact ordering okay
and so
on the other hand at the other end of
the complexity scale learning to rank
methods are very expensive
um and so we're not going to discuss
this today so the idea is simply today
to connect the pairwise preference
problem to another problem that that
also talks about ordering but based on a
completely different information set
which is uh ranking based on similarity
or seriation okay
so i'm just going to make the connection
between this pairwise
the disordering from pairwise
preferences problem to another problem
uh looking at similarity matrices
looking at similarity between vibers and
trying to recover and ordering based on
these similarities okay yes
so
uh which category of the about the elo
thing fall into does that fall into the
scoring methods category or
which one this one
so
uh the yellow yellow one oh hilo is is
at least in in
the references i'm citing here is in the
scoring category
no no it's not i had very broad
statements again
and robust to what also so there are
many things you can do to this this
information to torture it you have
typically missing values you can have
corruption uh you can have adversarial
so the list goes on and on and on and so
very broad statements but i'm going to
talk about robustness in more precise
terms towards the end of the talk
yes
what's the property of that one that
we're trying to improve what's the
property that the elo wanna have oh
typically the sum of these cars you you
you switch one value somewhere suppose
you have the full information matrix i
mean i i'll have a few slides that say
this later on but i might as well say it
now you start with the full information
matrix all preferences are fixed they
are consistent with the total order and
you switch one
and that's that's going to be enough
master you suddenly will become like
whatever your pharmacy is and so you
switch one um you you create ambiguity
in some of these core uh methods and and
typically you don't and again typically
should be qualified but you typically
don't in the spectrum methods
that's that's what i i wanted to say
yes when do algorithms follow
minimum feedback for example oh so you
remember that slide with uh with uh
methods ranked according to increasing
complexity
i think that this would be somewhere
here okay uh but but on the other hand
it's a pts so
um and and again the metric of
performance is slightly different and so
on so
so that's it that was
just an introduction
second introduction introduction
creation i talked about it here last
year but uh i had two slides to sort of
refresh your memory three actually
so seriation is pretty easy to describe
as well okay it's a very natural problem
you have pairwise similarity information
aig on n vivas okay
so you know aig measure measures how
close vibes i and j are that's it
symmetric
yes yeah this one completely symmetric
and so um
and and we're going to make one key
assumption and this is really important
which is that the data has a serial
structure
okay so you're essentially measuring
a similarity on on objects sitting in a
one-dimensional manifold so you unfold
it and then then the geometry works
right okay
and and you can formalize that
in in in
numbers so function mapping between the
two is arbitrary i mean as long as it's
decreasing for now yes yeah yeah and so
all you want is this r matrix property
that says that there is a permutation of
your matrix and so that characterizes
this serial structure there's a
permutation of your matrix
where the
coefficients are decreasing as you move
away from the diagonal
sorry the definition of r matrix do you
want to say that the entries decrease
with pi r minus 5 j
uh no no no so you want it it's given
you you're not given the the the viable
the the matrix sorry in an ordered way
so there has to be so for this condition
to hold there has to be a permutation of
your matrix such that the coefficients
move away from the diagonal right but
the coefficient is more way after
permutation right ah yes uh could be yes
yes sorry then yeah so are you assuming
that there are only two
values in this matrix no this one is
stupid uh by by accident so so i could
generate a much more sophisticated
example with bumps and so on it doesn't
matter you all you want is the decrease
away from the diagonal so there should
be it's it's easier to spell spell out
graphically there should be one
permutation of the matrix at least that
puts it in this tenth format what does
it mean exactly i mean if it's not top
blitz then what do you mean by your way
you just uh yeah then away becomes a so
it has to be decreased column wise and
otherwise
yeah
yes so um
the question is minus g pi of i minus pi
of t yes yes
so forget about the permutation thing so
the matrix when properly ordered should
look like this
okay except this one is a bit too simple
because it's depletes but something like
that so it should decrease as you move
away from the diagonal along lines and
columns okay
and that's natural you have a chain so
your your vibe is organized around a
chain you move away from one viable
along that chain and if things are
properly unfolded then clearly the
similarity should decrease okay
okay so that's the r matrix assumption
and that defines the this
this serial structure
i was mentioning okay so typically
seriation problem is easy to spread out
your input is not this it looks like
this
right and you have a permutation you
have to find a permutation of your
matrix that reconstructs it in in this
in this way finds recovers the exact
ordering
okay so that's a combinatorial problem
written over permutations and so on it
should be hard but it turns out that
this is one of the rare examples where
you have exact reconstruction results
for spectral clustering
okay so
you can reconstruct you can solve this
problem explicitly provided that this
assumption holds in a slightly stricter
version so you need strict inequalities
in a few places and so on but roughly
speaking this is the id provide that
your data has this serial structure
then applying
spectral clustering to the similarity
matrix which means forming the laplacian
and computing its second smallest
eigenvector the fiddler vector
and recovering and ordering from the
ordering of the coefficients of this
eigenvector
that will provide you with the uh
permutation you're looking for the one
that reorder the
orders the matrix in in our format yes
what's priyar priyaris
is a permutation of uh yeah there's a
lot there are slides missing here this
is a permutation of an hour matrix okay
so you apply spectral clustering to the
laplacian of the disordered matrix you
recover the eigenvector you sort its
coefficients that gives you a
permutation that permutation will
reorder the matrix okay it's magical and
again the computational cost of this is
minimal it just sends coal again
okay
so it's used there there are many
applications of this thing but one
completely explicit is
gene sequencing
it's not used actually right now in gene
sequencing but it's a good illustration
of a problem that looks very close to
that typically we we cannot read genomes
long strands of genome so what people do
is that they clone the genes
cut them into small pieces that can be
sequenced explicitly
and then reassemble the pieces by
looking at the similarity between the
edges of those genome pieces and then
average the result once reordered
and
construct a consensus sequence okay
so the similarity information for these
small pieces of genes uh they're called
reads are typically things that look
very much like overlap okay you look at
the overlap between the the
edges of these reads and and that gives
you a measure of similarity typically uh
reads coming from completely different
parts of the genome will not overlap so
you get a similarity of zero and then
when there is significant overlap the
similarity increases that's all you need
and and genes have naturally this serial
structure okay
so that's variation and so the idea
today is to make the connection between
uh
reconstructing rankings from pairwise
preference information and seriation
both are ordering problems
or ranking problems if you want
and where is the connection and it turns
out that the answer is is extremely
simple and
and also
you can say a lot about the stability of
the solution much more so than in other
spectral solutions
yes you are implying that the matrix is
full all the entries are available right
um yes but then i'll start from the
solution where the matrix is full and
then study what happens when you start
to remove entries or corrupt them that's
that's what i mean by robustness or
stability
and and it turns out that in some cases
you can remove a lot of entries
so the matrix is not so fully anymore
but it depends exactly what kind of
regimes and
error bounds you're looking for okay
so how do we go from this pairwise
ranking from
pairwise preference information
to seriation well the answer is
deceptively simple
so
suppose you store all your pairwise
comparisons in this matrix c
okay it's plus one if i is ranked higher
than c i j is plus 1 if i is ranked
higher than j
0 if the
comparison is missing or there's a draw
minus 1 if j is ranked higher than i and
so on
and you're going to define a
pairwise similarity matrix s match
as
essentially this quantity here and what
does this do well it simply counts the
number of matching comparisons between i
and j
with all other reference items k
and the intuition is is very simple
you're in a tournament setting
and the idea here is to say that players
that beat the same players and are
beaten by the same players should have
similar rankings okay so that's all
you're encoding here you have your
tournament result information here and
you're computing a similarity matrix
between players based on two players
will be closing the rankings if they are
defeated and beat the same players okay
that's that's what you're measuring here
and in the in the case where you have a
full information consistent with the
total order everything is ordered etc
s match has a very simple format it's
simply n minus the difference between
i and j
okay
and that's a strict r matrix
so when properly ordered
the
similarity matrix computed from the
comparisons
um
has satisfies this serial r matrix
condition
which makes spectral clustering work
okay
in other words that's one way of
deriving a very simple spectral method
for ranking from pairwise preferences
you take the preferences construct a
similarity matrix and reorder the
similarity matrix using spectral
clustering that's it
okay
and of course that's one way to do it
all you need to be able to do is to
construct a similarity matrix that
satisfies this r matrix assumption
so
whatever your flavor of preference is as
long as it satisfies this r matrix
condition
uh it will work in particular what you
can do is try to increase the the
contrast for example by adding powers
here so there's there's an infinite
number of variations on this this
methodology it's just a new way of
generating uh ranking algorithms
spectral ranking algorithms okay but
i guess it's not just enough that you
decrease away from the diagram you need
to decrease at some rate away from that
there's no rate
but you need you need strict
inequalities in a few places so uh the
the sort of easiest way to prove this
result is with a condition that states
that the feeder vector should be
strictly monotonic
and if that's true then then and the
result is based on the parent forbidden
argument i i haven't had time to mention
it but typically monotonic vector is a
vector whose increments are always
positive and so the proof works along
the lines of the for venus result
that's where it's coming from it's it's
a paper by atkins and others in 98 so
there's a reference in the talk if
you're interested but there's no there
are no conditions on rates or anything
there are a few technical conditions on
the and to make sure that things are
unique and you don't have degeneracy but
that's it
okay
so
once you have that strict r matrix
assumption
you know that uh spectral clustering
will recover the the two order so that's
one way to do it but you can also do it
if you wanted to generalize in our model
how does it work in two lines very easy
you have these probabilities you measure
them empirically and you form
you estimate a matrix sglm which is
again
one minus the difference of the observed
probabilities of winning okay
and if you have enough samples at one
point this matrix is going to become an
r matrix and so applying spectral
clustering to it will i cover the troll
ranking okay
um and so
uh just to summarize these results very
quickly again if the items are ordered
by decreasing values of the skill
parameters the similarity matrix sgml
sglm is a straight r matrix which means
that spectral clustering will recover
the two ranking same thing
okay so now robustness i have a few more
seconds to tell you about
why inherently at least trying to
convince you
that spectral methods are inherently
robust at least these ones and the
reason for that is that those matrices
are so simple that you can say pretty
much everything you need
about their spectrum
and if you know everything you need
about the spectrum you know everything
you need about robustness because then
you can use perturbation arguments
completely explicitly
okay
so
there are first a few things you can say
just using counting and combinatorial
methods so for example robustness to
corrupted entries if you're given all
comparisons between items order one and
they're all consistent except one that
you switch and the gap between these two
is larger than two
then the matrix will remain a strict r
matrix which means that again spectral
clustering will recover the the
correct order okay so uh there's a
graphical way of seeing why this works
this is the comparison matrix well
ordered with the full information set
consistent with the total ordering the
similarity constructed from this
exact full information matrix this is
the similarity after one entry is
corrupted the comparison between three
and eight
and you see that uh i mean you see it's
not immediately obvious but what makes
things work here is that the strict r
assumption is still satisfied okay
and that would not be the case for
example of a border count method okay
so um you can actually generalize this
argument a little bit more further again
this is a kind of completely direct
combinatorial algorithm and show that
actually square root of n
corruptions will work
with with high probability
if you pick them
you if you locate them at random okay
um so
you you know that you need at least n
square comparisons for exact recovery so
clearly you won't be able to go
up to and square
but it's not clear exactly where this
stops so it might be possible to do more
we can't do that yet but i'll switch to
another argument later and
as far as i know there's no exact
recovery result of this type for the
markov chain type spectrum methods
okay so
what's interesting here is that the
matrix you form to reconstruct the two
ordering
is extremely simple okay this is just uh
minus one plus one okay
and the similarity
if it's a
arbitrary like a
for adversarial choice of the n squared
comparison because generally you would
think for exact recovery
um if they're picked uniform
if they pick uniformly at random then
logan should be enough right um
no no no so here you need n square
for exact recovery but for it's for
exact
exact recovery if there is a global
ordering yes and i tell you and i give
you
n log n
comparisons wouldn't that be enough to
i don't think so no no
the argument's really silly it's almost
like somehow that it's a bit counting
that i could flip something yeah
yeah
i have to be robust like what me has you
have to get it exactly yeah it's exact
here there are there are softer versions
of this result where things are
completely different and where you get
to and log in
so if you're allowed to if you allow
sort of a local uh you want to constrain
how much error you're going to make
then you get results at the rate and
again so if you if you just care about
not being too far then n log n is okay
and it's actually optimal clearly but
but if you care about being exact then n
log n doesn't work anymore okay
um
so
here the the sort of good news about
this method compared for example other
spectral methods where you have this
markov chain matrix is that the matrix
whose spectrum you're computing is
extremely simple it's templates linear
decrease and so on and so you know
pretty much everything you need to know
about its spectrum and it's much easier
to analyze than other markov chain based
methods okay so in particular we can
compute its field of vector
asymptotically
and uh same thing for the normalized
there are two versions so i'm not going
to go into details but there are two
versions of spectral clustering
normalized and normalized the normalized
sorry the non-symmetric normalized
laplacian is even simpler to analyze
because it's a fiddler vector is uh
of this form x i equals to a constant
times i
so it's uniformly increasing
and um in addition to that uh so not
only can you compute the fiddler vector
explicitly in this case at least
asymptotically you can also control the
spectral graph very precisely and the
spectral gap is what defines robustness
for these matrices okay so if you can
bound the gap between the the first the
second and the third eigenvalue you know
exactly how robust your method is going
to be to small perturbations missing
values and corrupted entries and here
it's the case because you know exactly
how to analyze the spectrum you know
pretty much everything you need to know
about the spectrum of these matrices so
this is just a direct application of
results by von neuxberg and and others
in a
in on the consistency of spectral
clustering this is a spectral crossing
algorithm so it's not a surprise
asymptotically s match normalize
converges to this linear operator the
degree function has this explicit format
you know for based on these results that
the range of the degree well no the
range of the degree is between 0.5 and
0.75 and you know from this this paper
then the bulk of the spectrum has to be
contained in this an interval
so the bulk of the spectrum is in this
interval you can also show that the
second negative value is outside of this
interval you can control the gap and so
you can control the stability of the
perturbation argument in this case okay
and so this this control on the space
spectral gap means you can use
perturbation analysis to study the
robustness of recovery completely
explicitly typically getting the
secondary vector or getting information
on the spectral gap is the hard part in
showing robustness the key difference
here is that the matrices are so simple
that you can you get everything
explicitly okay
and so this is the classical result uh
showing by how much the ordering will be
corrupted based on how much error you're
making on the laplacian
because of missing or corrupted
comparisons this is the impact of the
spectral gap
okay
you have an explicit formula for the
perturbation but it depends on on the
rest of the spectrum and you
don't necessarily compute that
but typically if the an infinity norm of
the difference in these two vectors is
smaller than the initial gap between
your fiddler vector coefficients
you're still going to have exact
recovery because you're not going to be
switching any coefficients and so that
means that if the error in the laplacian
is small enough whatever this error is
you get exact recovery so this
simple perturbation analysis shows you
that there's a region around the true
matrix where you get exact recovery
okay and so very briefly we're not done
yet with those results so it's a bit
sort of a high level
discussion but the way you corrupt the
matrix is also highly classical
because you essentially corrupt the
preference information matrix by
subsampling it so you have zeros
appearing in the preference matrix and
we know exactly what the impact of
subsampling is on the spectrum because
it's actually a method used in
randomized lineage about to speed up the
computation of svds you zero out certain
coefficients and that speeds up the
metric vector matrix vector products
you're doing in aggregate value
computations okay
and so
there are results for example in
nashville tests in actually showing
how to bound
the error in the
laplacian matrix in this case based on
the number of entries you're keeping
okay
so unfortunately
the the perturbation argument
does not allow us yet to improve the
rate the square root of n results on the
number of allowed perturbation that we
got
previously but at least all the
ingredients are there so hopefully we'll
get something a bit more precise so
okay so i have zero minutes but i'll
take two
um so this is just a graph illustrating
the difference at dimension 100 between
the asymptotic formula and the true one
for the fielder vector so the the point
of this graph is that there is no
difference
um and so very quickly i'll illustrate a
few numerical results so we
essentially have a new algorithm a new
class of methods for producing uh
ranking algorithms out of pairwise
preference information
i'm sorry these are for our matrices
those matrices that you will find
so here we take a pairwise preference a
tournament matrix constructed from a
total ordering
and uh we arbitrarily
uniformly corrupt it or
suppress entries
so the matrix does not have before you
corrupt it it doesn't have to be
in our matrix oh no no it's just a
preference information matrix but if you
square it and it's exact then it's going
to be an r matrix the entries are 0 1 or
minus 1 yes
but they're all plus one minus one if
you're looking at the full matrix
initially okay and so there's there's no
clear winners so the long story short
there's no clear winning method so
i guess by design the method i presented
here and some of these experiments at
least does better than than the others
this is bradley terry lewis this is
wrong centrality the other spectrum
method this is the scoring and and in
red is is the seriation based result so
it does better when you don't have when
you're near the exact noiseless regime
okay in these experiments but it's not
always the case sometimes you have this
non-linear behavior that we don't
understand clearly it behaves completely
differently
that's at least all you can say
so here this was higher is better we
knew the ground truth here we don't we
just minimized the the number we just
studied the number of upsets this is on
the top coder coding competition and
again you see that uh well at least on
both these examples
this spectral solution so the the
seriation-based solution does better
than the wrong centrality spectral
solution
it does of course all these are going to
do better than the point score and the
both partly loose and the
seriation-based algorithm do better than
the
system used by the topcoder website okay
you can do supervised
honking recovery but i'm not going to
talk about that and of course none of
these results are stable so this is a
top quarter over the years so this is
one year where things were very
noisy not that noisy and this these are
two years where it's not clear at all
what's going on okay
but at least the behavior is completely
different so uh there's some innovation
this was presented in britain so they
wanted to know about football um and so
just to finish we were i'm recording a
little bit of advertising am i coaching
postdocs for one or two years at the
conglomerate superior
this is more or less the view from our
office
and
and so if you're interested send me an
email at this address and so just to
conclude thank you for giving me a few
more minutes
we have a new way of generating uh
ranking algorithms spectral ranking
algorithms based on seriation results
and essentially what is an exact
recovery result for spectral clustering
um
and the the nice thing about this result
here is that there is an almost
completely explicit perturbation
analysis and it's not that frequent that
you can go as far in the details in the
way you analyze perturbations here
everything is computable which is really
nice
and it seems to be more robust in
certain settings
and coming soon so
we have talked a lot about what happens
near the regime where you have full
information it's noiseless and so on and
we need to say a bit more about the
other end the one you were talking about
where you're close to n logan at the
completely other end of the information
spectrum and we don't have good
stability results there so that's that's
to do the paper will be at nips in uh in
december and and there's a subset of
these results on ourselves thank you
i guess it's probably something that you
covered in your top 10 but uh so there
is this model model of braverman and
mosul where they flip the
comparisons with probability excellent
right some half minus incidence okay and
they give an algorithm to recover the
rankings
based algorithm to recover the rankings